i'm i'm appalled and i'm shocked
and um
honestly i just don't know what the
future holds for us
well now we know 90 day fiance stars eve
and mohammed are calling it quits and
eve's been charged with battery and
assault i never felt like
there was going to be any issues
the breakup and battery charge come
after a bombshell reveal on the latest
90-day fiance tell-all special i want to
make that right i texted this one i told
her i am a married man
please stop texting me anymore
i know i did wrong all i can do now is
saying story to my wife the couple
confessing on sunday's episode that
after filming the season eve caught
muhammad cheating on her with another
woman and allegedly text messages
between muhammad and that woman suggests
he was only using eve for a green card i
do like eve and
she doesn't deserve that what do you say
to viewers who feel as if muhammad is
manipulative i would say kind of like
those blanket statements sometimes
aren't necessarily based in fact so you
know that's
can be a little frustrating to me
yet two months later and eve's answer to
that question might be different now
that we know about a police incident
that took place on august 15th that's
when albuquerque authorities reportedly
charged eve with battery and assault
against a household member charges she
denies her court date is scheduled for
september 6. and now her rep is speaking
out exclusively to e.t about the whole
ordeal saying mohammed created these
false accusations as a backup plan to
get a u-visa a type of green card that
lets foreigners stay in the u.s if
they've been victims of a crime
that way he would stay in the u.s and
not get deported
as for muhammad's response well he's
mostly keeping quiet posting just this
message to instagram quote a lot of
people asking why i'm not saying my part
of the story that's because i was trying
my best to end my relationship with
respect that's all babe why are you
sending me this
you're saying if i don't get the
paperwork done i'm you're going to get
like another sponsor or something i'm
trying to figure it out it's possible
you can't do that baby i'm the sponsor
i'm your i'm your petitioner you can't
just like come to this country and get
another sponsor
eve's rep goes on to say that there is
no proof of muhammad's domestic violence
allegations against her going so far as
to claim eve has security footage that
would prove her innocence mohammed was
just so different than anybody that i
ever met like he literally like saw
straight through me like into my soul
for him to just be able to tune in to me
like
to me was such a deep emotional
connection and he just conveyed to me
even though he wasn't physically here
that he had my back
well now it seems it's the end of the
road for these two as eve's team says
divorce is the likely next step
[Music]